Is this is just our social gang?
And it's just us? I think that's a problem.
Hi, I'm Nick Gillespie with Reason TV and I am
talking with Jeff Tucker. He is the
Director of Content at the Foundation
for Economic Education—which I think is
the oldest—longest-lived
libertarian organization. Crazy. Look it
was founded in 1946.
1946. Which we don't know
anything about that.
Yeah. But we we actually know from the
history books what was going on. Price
controls—you know—heavily regulated
industry. It was a wartime economy and a lot
of people at the time thought
that liberalism—oh, liberalism— was
dead and gone. But a handful of people—you
know—including Lawrence Fertig, Leonard Read—
you know it was just really a
small, small group. And wasn't like
Ludwig von Mises always hanging out out there?
So that's an interesting thing because he
came over 1940 and didn't really have a
home, anywhere really. He wanted to stay
in New York so he didn't have a
university position. Well FEE brought him on board.
And made him a kind of a house
intellectual. You know Henry Hazlitt
at the time who wrote
Economics in One Lesson in 1946 also. And so
when I went to work for FEE I went back
because I wanted to do something about
reviving it's editorial mission.
I didn't want to do the same thing
everybody else was doing. I wanted to do
something different. And I wanted to
figure out maybe there's
something we're missing.
So I went back and looked at the early
writings of all these guys from the
1940s and I tell you
I found something really interesting and
it might be of interest to you. There weren't a lot
of what we call libertarians around at the time.
They didn't have any—they didn't
have like we have a movement, you know?
So that had posed a special editorial burden
on them. They had to speak in a way to
everybody or to anyone who would listen.
And I think that affected the way they
thought and the way they wrote. So they
had to like every piece had to sort of
make sense for anybody who happened to pick it up.
So there—in that they're showing
their math. They're making their
arguments clear. They're not assuming a
lot of foreknowledge. That's right.
And they're not using
a specialized language, right? So
they know better than to—and it's
very different from us today.
But they spoke to a general—
a general audience in the values of the time.
Trying to make a practical case
for human liberty.
In the early stages of FEE publications did they link
economics to that broader issue of
human liberty? There was always a moral concern and
it's interesting because I saw a
correspondence between Ayn Rand and
Leonard Read. And she really wanted the
organization to be called something like—
I don't know— the Institute for the
Defense of Radical Capitalism or something like that.
And Leonard was—you know
he came out of industry.
He came out of commerce and he understood
sales and marketing. And he knew that if
he called it the Foundation for Economic
Education—something very plain and
innocuous—that they could
push radical ideas in a mainstream framework.
And wasn't one of their early
publications —I may be getting this wrong—
but it was something with
Milton Friedman and Stigler talking about
rent control? Yes. And that was the
piece that drew Murray Rothbard my
old friend in an exciting
relationship with the ideas of liberty.
And they did this with many
people. Now the height of the
Friedman circulation was
achieved in the 1960s with fifty thousand.
Which, I mean, Reason gets that every day.
And we do now. So it was a small
market —relatively small market. But what I
think is interesting is that they had a
big job and they had really nowhere
to begin but just reaching mainstream people.
And here's the thing. I think we
have something to learn from that.
Because as we've become a movement—
that's very exciting. We love the movement and we
talk with libertarians. We come to libertarian events.
We're at Students for
Liberty where they've got about 1,700 kids
from a hundred countries. And we all—
we're all in the same Facebook groups and we
follow each other on Twitter.
And that's good.
Nothing bad about that. But it does give
rise to—I think—certain temptations to
speak in our own vernacular or our own
really high liturgical language with
each other. Then normal people
can't understand.
And it also tempts us to sort of dig ever
deeper into sectarian battles—
and here's the other thing—it's a matter of how we think
of ourselves.
Are we a chosen, marginalized
group that's going to be
forever hanging around together?
Is this just our social gang?
And it's just us? I think that's a problem.
So what are some of the articles that
you do that you try to reach a broader
general audience. So I don't know
if you're ever tempted to do this as an editor,
but I've never done this before. I've never tried this before.
But I try to classify every article
as either in-reach or outreach.
And by that I mean are we
cultivating the libertarian spirit
among the already convinced? Or am I creating
a piece of content that you as a
libertarian might be willing to share on
your Facebook account, even though your
pastor or your mother, your friends from high school are on it
because you found it compelling enough.
And what I've learned from the metrics
is that this is the challenge. To create
content that gets the second, third, and fourth share.
What's like the most
recent piece you did that was successful in those terms?
Well you mentioned my review of "The Young Pope" and we—
So"The Young Pope" is the HBO show with
Jude Law and—were you raised
Catholic by any chance? Well— [CROSSTALK]
but you're familiar? I've had a big
relationship with Catholicism [CROSSTALK]
So I was raised Catholic and I
actually I love it. I'm a
prolapsed Catholic at this point. I'm like
totally—it's collapsed and it's not coming
back.  You'll never be anything but
ex-Catholic, Nick. You can't get away from it.
But I mean I love the show. But talk a
little bit about that piece because that
seemed to be doing something that you're talking about.
That's the kind of thing we. We try to review all the new stuff on Netflix.
And we try to write regular reviews. In other words
I'm looking for a libertarian spin
on things. I want really regular reviews
that I as a libertarian am
going to write because I see things
differently than other people. And I hope to
add value to it you know?
One of the things we used to talk about
at Reason and over the years
you come up with different things.
But we wanted to be not—we didn't want
to just be a magazine for libertarians.
We wanted to be a magazine by libertarians
because your worldview would fill out.
[CROSSTALK] I think that's a good way to
think about it. That's a good way to think about it.
Reason does a good job of this. What was
your insight for "The Young Pope"?
Because I thought it was kind of clever.
I think the whole thing was structured
in a way to respond to the rise of
a kind of reactionary right. In Europe
and in the United States. And this show is very
popular in Italy. So the young pope
shows up. He had a regular career. He had
the perfect bishop career. Just the right
training and never revealed much about
himself. Just very pastoral as they say.
They knew he was a conservative because
of course look at his teachers and look
at his temperament and that sort of thing.
What they didn't know is that he had
a hard agenda and really a kind of
revanchist agenda to recapture what
would have been lost. And he really does
adopt all these forms that are
essentially pre-Vatican too. And
there are moments in the thing that just had
me just cracking up. He delayed
weeks his opening lecture to the College of
Cardinals and by
the final thing the thing comes along
he's carried in on a chair and wearing
the most outrageous liturgical gear
seeming to revive the temporal power.
Oh, and he brings back the triple crown
which Paul VI gave away.
He gets it shipped from Washington.
And then at the same time he is
hyper-conservative or traditional but he
breaks all the forms.
He even starts smoking again in
the Vatican which is— And also I
think it was very interesting for me to
follow it because his commitment was
entirely intellectual but it wasn't
organically connected with the real
experience of the church now.
And what he finds
is that there's no going back. Which is
not to say that it's inevitable,
we're going to do forever and it tended in
Francis direction. The point is that
whatever you're going to build you have
to build from what actually really exists.
Well and you also talked about it how
"The Young Pope"— and again this is a show
that was filmed in Italy a year or a year
and a half ago. So it's pre-Trump but he's
also kind of the perfect—one way to talk
about Trump because he has a very set—
strong set of views that he is going to
force on people. Whether he likes it or not.
[CROSSTALK] I read reviews
of things partly because I'm dodging my
own deadlines but it's also like I had a
professor once who said, "Look, any
criticism is good if it makes the
thing more interesting and I
thought that your Young Pope piece
worked really well. Now had you seen it?
Yeah. And you still liked my review?
Oh, totally. It gave you some
insight. No and it—
it also made me think about Trump
who you know I'm not a fan of
Trump. One of the things though I do find
attractive about him is his willingness
to break with decorum and just be like
shut the fuck up like we're doing it my
way now. And he will say this is the way
it should always be done. And that is—it's
chaos inducing. I think it is not principled—
And maybe we need that. [CROSSTALK] It can
make an opening for more radical politics I hope.
I hope that that's true. You know on the
other side, we had a review of this
movie about Queen Elizabeth II—"The Crown."
And now there you have an opposite
case. Because you have somebody who—
a similar leader but she throws
away her personality, her personal desires,
her own individual wishes and everything
out of deference to the long tradition.
And in a way "The Crown" makes the case
that there's merit in that too because
the disturbance itself can create an
atmosphere in which bad things can
happen. She wants to defer to the past.
And in fact in the previous
generation you know they had the king
that renounced his crown. [CROSSTALK] Edward.
For the sake of love.
For the sake of love. And the monarchy was like
don't ever do anything like that because
that's not what the people need.
But that show makes the
case for
more of a continuity or a slow change. I think
we as libertarians are drawn to
both. Part of us—
part of us wants to disturb and upset
and overthrow. [CROSSTALK]  Part of this is
also a little concerned about it that.
This is the difference between a
kind of like Rothbard and Hayek perhaps.
I think that the difference between Rothbard and Hayek is very interesting.
You know I think all good
libertarians toggle between Hayek and Rothbard.
Well we will stop it here, but what I
want to congratulate you on, because this—
you know is really revitalizing FEE
and I mean the material is good.
This opens up a way of talking about
libertarianism as well as ideas as well
as current popular culture in ways that
are just—it's very generative.
Liberty is everything and it belongs to
everybody. And we should speak to
everybody I think. And not think of
ourselves as a small sect, but as Mises
said, "For the common good,
for everybody."
We've been talking with Jeff Tucker. He
is the Director of Content at the
Foundation for Economic Education. FEE dot org.
Jeff, thanks so much. It's my pleasure.
For Reason TV, I'm Nick Gillespie.